so yeah today I'm going to talk about a
problem which really is used a lot in
numerical weather prediction but it's a
lot bigger than numerical weather
prediction America weather prediction is
already big but this is a very generic
problem it's a problem that is relevant
to data scientists I think it's a
problem where you want to make
predictions but your data is very sparse
you also have a lot of prior information
about the data you know that it comes
from a model so it's time evolving data
that comes from a model that you know
something about the model however is not
a good model for making predictions so
we're going to be looking at oops
chaotic models chaotic models are not
good at making predictions small
uncertainties in your information about
current state can lead to large
uncertainties in predictions so we want
to try and combine these two pieces of
information want to combine the model
that we have and the data to try and
make better predictions so I'm a
mathematician I have to warn you I tried
to scrub as much math from my slides as
I could but some things are left over
and particularly the first slide has
math so I'll give you a toy example of a
model which fits into this framework
this is called the Lorentz equations
it's a three-dimensional ordinary
differential equation so it's just a
point in three-dimensional space moving
around the velocity of the point is a
function of where the point is in space
it has these three parameters Sigma Rho
beta and for certain choices of these
parameters this is a chaotic model and
that means that you can have two initial
conditions of the equation that are
close together and if you watch them
evolve in time they'll separate and have
nothing to do with each other anymore so
that large decay of correlations in how
close things are together
so this is you can think of this as kind
of a toy atmospheric model you can write
down honest-to-god models for the
atmosphere do a very crude approximation
of it and arrive at something like this
so even though it's a toy model it does
have something to do with real models
like atmospheric models so i'll just
show you the plot of what a single
trajectory of this model looks like so
you can understand what it means what
how is data revolving in time so i
started at one point and this is what
happens as i have all been time it'll
trace out a shape which might be
familiar to some of you so this is
called the butterfly attractor or the
Lorenz attractor so essentially what
happens is no matter where you start you
get sucked into this lower dimensional
part of your three dimensional space
which has a very complicated structure
at this butterfly shape and every time
you cross the to every time you get
close to the two lobes it's extremely
difficult to know which direction you'll
take it's extremely hard to predict
whether you'll go stick on the left or
go over to the right so this is what
gives you this kind of barrier to
prediction okay so now I want you to
imagine that this is what's happening in
reality and this is the thing that we
want to predict but we don't actually
know exactly where it started we know
approximately where it started so what
happens if we only knew approximately
where I started for instance if we had
ten different ideas of where was and we
started those ten ideas and float them
forward in time so this is maybe 10 so
they do roughly the same thing until
they reach the butterfly once they get
in on to this attractor their behavior
becomes almost random they completely
forget that they ever had anything to do
with each other so this is barrier to
making predictions so if you look at the
dots they're just wandering randomly
only attractive now so they have nothing
to do with each other anymore so this is
the barrier to predictions that you have
in a model
this is not something that's special to
these chaotic models this is just a
property of randomness so this is a very
generic product problem for any model
that has some kind of prediction barrier
this is kind of just a nice way of
illustrating that it can actually happen
in deterministic models where there's no
randomness okay so the model by itself
is not great for making predictions so
what if we had data from the one true
trajectory maybe not the whole point if
we add the whole data point then we
wouldn't really need the model at all so
what if we just had part of the data
point for example suppose that we just
observed the X variable out of the three
variables we just observed the first and
you observe it with a bit of noise as
well you observe it every cow seconds so
every towel seconds you get a new data
point and it's perturbed by some noise
because your measurement is kind of
noisy and you want to try and use this
additional data to make your estimate
battle so can we take those ten ideas
that are evolving in time the ensemble
of different predictions that we had and
blend them with the data in such a way
that they make the prediction better so
what we're doing here so each one of
these dots is one of my predictions
every thao seconds I'm assimilating a
new data point the blue curve is the
true thing that's producing the data
what happens over time is that the dots
all converge to each other and
eventually they converge to the right
thing and stay there forever so this is
called data assimilation you have a
problem where separately the two things
don't have enough information but if you
combine the two pieces of information in
the right way you can make good
predictions you can track the signal so
it's kind of it's not just a prediction
problem because we to do this we need
the data now so we can't we're not
really making predictions it's more like
we're making spatial predictions we have
incomplete data and we want to know what
are the other data points that we can't
see
and you could also think if we knew
where we are now then we can use that
fact to make a better prediction in the
future okay so the point of this talk is
to try and so this is not this is a toy
model that I've shown you it's not just
for toy models though this is huge
business so techniques like this have
been used for numerical weather
prediction basically since computers
have existed so for 70 years or
something the methods that they use are
extremely ad hoc to begin with and have
been getting more and more sophisticated
over time the models that they use are
not three-dimensional at all they're
extremely high dimensional so you can
think think of them as you take a PDE
which is describing maybe a section of
the ocean or the atmosphere a partial
differential equation you discretize it
to a level of resolution that you care
about we only care about what the ocean
looks like say at 100 meter by a 100
kilometer by 100 kilometer mesh this
gives you something that is extremely
high dimensional if you do it for a
large space of the earth and it's not
just that you care there's there's so
many different variables that you care
about at each point in space you care
about pressure you care about
temperature you care about ocean
currents this gives you an extremely
high dimensional model it's also a
turbulent model it's a chaotic model in
the sense that even if it wasn't random
small differences in initial conditions
would lead to large differences further
down the line when they use these models
operationally they actually put random
is in that you just account for
everything they don't know so everything
you don't know in your model all the
effects from the small scales that you
can't possibly account for a new model
you just model it with randomness you
just replace your uncertainty with true
randomness so in operation these models
are huge dimensional very hard to
predict often genuinely random
the observations that you make their
things like I drop of a boy in the ocean
I let it float around the boy is GPS
activated what does that tell me about
the ocean currents I have weather
balloons that move around that make
measurements of pressure they give me
extremely sparse data measurements
because it's the pressure at one point
in space you have satellite images to
take low-resolution images of the earth
it's not a great data point because
there's clouds and things that get in
the way of the stuff you really want to
see so it's obscured it's fast it's
noisy but we want to try and combine
this extremely sparse very diverse
amount of data with the model so you
should think of it as very sparse it's
actually quite accurate in the sense
that when you make measurements the
noise isn't that huge there's things
that stop you from measuring something
that you don't really call that noise
you say your measurement isn't available
in that sense like a cloud and you just
throw the data away and the
observational data is not just observed
the X variable it's observed some
complicated function of the variables
like what effect does it have on a boy
floating in the ocean ok so for the next
twenty five slides roughly and tell you
a bit about the math behind data
assimilation so what is the real
mathematical problem that you're trying
to get at when you write down an
algorithm to achieve this task I'll
explain what happens in the linear model
scenario this gives you something called
the cullman filter which I guess some of
you have heard of before and then what
happens in the nonlinear model scenario
so Karmin filters have existed for a
while they came out in the 60s and have
been hugely successful for numerical
weather prediction they're not linear
models at all and you need to use ideas
to try and extend linear ideas to
nonlinear models so the last part of the
talk I'll try and tell you about that
so the math of data assimilation so
suppose that we're tracking a
d-dimensional vector un whose motion is
governed by a discrete-time random
dynamical system ok what does all this
mean so you n is a vector is evolving in
time n is the index the time index of
the vector a discrete-time random
dynamical system means you take your
point at time n you apply some function
to it which takes it somewhere else and
then you add noise so a dynamical system
is if you just apply to function to it a
random dynamical system is if it's a
random function so this is just a very
specific example of a random function
you move your point around and then you
add noise to it so it's a very simple
model but actually a model that's used a
lot so you could think that in numerical
weather prediction you often have this
map whoops this Maps I is saying solve
my oh de for some amount of time putting
you in un as the initial condition and
then solve it for Chow seconds what
happened to that point in town seconds
that's the output of sy the noisy you
add on is to have count for the fact
that your model wasn't perfect you have
some kind of uncertainty in your model
so you add noise to reflect that you're
not actually that certain about your
model so sy n of e TN here is what
you're going to say it's an iid source
of Gaussian noise probably I idea is not
the best way to model this because
uncertainties that you have in your
model would be correlated in time so
it's not the best model but it's a good
starting point in the Lorenz example we
just took this to be 0 there was no
noise in the actual model here but you
don't have to take it to be 0 you could
put model in you dare to reflect
uncertainty
and sigh we're always going to think of
that as a deterministic map so the
problem is the initial state you zero is
not exactly known for instance we might
just know that it's distributed like
some Cashin so you could think that we
know the mean of where it is and we know
that it has some spread so what happens
as we evolve in time so in that
animation I showed you you could imagine
that we had this little tight gash in
and those ten points that we had with
samples from that caption and then as
they evolved in time they spread over
the whole attractor so if you imagine
what happened with we took this caption
and pushed it forward in time becomes a
distribution spread across the whole
attractor and you've lost all your
information you just know that you're
somewhere on the attractor but every
point is always somewhere on the
attractor so you basically lost all your
information we also have data so we make
partial noisy observations at every time
step so the data is some vector called
Zn plus 1 living in probably a much
lower dimensional space than the whole
state because it's a sparse data point
some function of the true state and we
have observational noise
so what we want to do how do we combine
the two pieces of information so the
correct way to do it probabilistically
is to define the conditional
distribution as what i mean by that so
if i take a randomly distributed you 0
and i push it through my model i get a
random variable i want to condition that
random variable on the data that i have
this gives me a new random variable but
hopefully one that has more information
than if i didn't condition on the data
by conditioning on the data i can rule
out things that I know didn't happen
it's still I still don't know exactly
what happened but hopefully I can reduce
my uncertainty by conditioning on the
data so that's what this conditional
distribution does so the UN is a random
variable we would like to know the
conditional distribution of un given all
the data up to now so not just given the
latest data point given every piece of
data that we've observed so far so we
can actually interpret this so we can
define this conditional distribution
nicely using bayes formula so base
formula sorry math how do we use base
formula so in the first line all i'm
doing here is i'm splitting off the
latest observation that you make so this
collection of all your data point 0 n
plus 1 you split off into ZN and then
the latest data point then we're going
to use bayes formula just on that latest
data point so leaving the capital ZM in
the conditional part of the conditional
distribution that allows us to factorize
this as a product of three things well a
ratio of three things the first term
that appears in the second line is
called a likelihood it's the likelihood
that you would have observed that
observation given that it was at you n
plus 1 the next term is what we call a
prior this is how likely is the state to
be at you n plus 1 just given all the
pre the pie
data so not given the new information
that i just got just given the past data
how likely am I to be at you n plus 1 so
this is my prior information in the
denominator that's just a normalization
factor doesn't matter so much it's just
a constant doesn't we care about how
this depends on you n plus 1 because
that tells us where the state is so the
normalization factor doesn't depend on
you n plus 1 it's just a constant so you
should think about this as this
conditional distribution is really
proportional to these two factors a
likelihood and a prior so we can use
this idea to perform an update procedure
so this doesn't make much sense or give
you a picture which hopefully will make
it make sense so this is this blue
circle here represents my uncertainty at
time n so this is the distribution
conditioned on everything I've observed
up to time n this is where I think what
I know about the true state at time n so
what do I do the first thing I do is I
apply my dynamics so I take that initial
uncertainty and I just flow it forward
using my dynamic so using this random
dynamical system so when you flow
something forward through a map or
dynamics that has uncertainty in it your
uncertainty will grow you will spread
out even more because small
uncertainties in the initial condition
lead to large and certainties later on
so we take we had our small uncertainty
and we got a bigger uncertainty so this
is our prior knowledge of where we are
at time n plus 1 not given any extra
data yet so this is what you call a
forecast distribution because you're
just taking what you knew a second ago
and your for cart you're making a
forecast using only the model
now we make an observation say that we
just observe 2 X variable so we only
know where it is on the X line so really
you should think of that observation is
like a line extending infinitely up the
y-axis but you know it's at that point
well I had noise so you know it's near
that point so to combine those two
pieces of information essentially you
take your forecast distribution and you
re weight it with this likelihood factor
a likelihood factor is how likely would
I be how likely am I to be at some point
say this point given that this was my
observation you're extremely unlikely to
be here if you observe that your x value
is here but you're much more likely to
be here so Yuri wait your forecast
distribution using the observation so
this green distribution is the re
weighted distribution this is your new
estimate for you and you're all the
information that you have about the
state at time n plus 1 given all the
data up to n plus 1 so invasion
terminology this is called the posterior
you have a prior which is what you
thought before you included the data and
then you have a posterior which is what
you thought after you included the data
so this is our posterior so this cycle
this is your new starting point once you
get the next observation so this creates
a cycle so this is called the filtering
cycle
so in the linear model scenario
everything has a formula which makes
this problem very nice so what I mean by
that so you have something called their
common filter in the linear model
scenario so when I say linear model I
assume that the maps I that
deterministic map is just a matrix so
the evolution is linear for the model
the observation function H I'm assuming
that's a linear as well so that's also
just a matrix you can think of that as
like a low dimensional projection if you
like so you just project on to some of
your data points or you mix up some of
your data points but it's still just a
linear map under this assumption the
conditional distribution or the
conditional random variable UN Givens at
n plus 1 is a Gaussian so when you take
something that's originally a Gaussian
you flow it forward under your model
it's still a Gaussian it's just a
caption with a different meaning
covariance you then condition on data
it's still like action as long as that
data was also cashed so the nice thing
about assuming everything is linear is
that the distribution that you care
about the posterior remains the caption
the nice thing about gaussians is that
they're completely characterized by
their mean and covariance so to
understand this distribution completely
you just need to formula for its mean
and covariance you can show that the
mean and covariance satisfies a
recursion formula so if you knew the
meeting Ric and covariance at time n you
can figure out the meaning of variance
of time n plus 1 so these are the famous
calm and formulas common update formulas
so it's basically telling us that it's
an extremely intuitive formula why is it
intuitive so you have two pieces of
information that are telling you what
your new mean should be they should be
your old mean push forward under your
model and also your data your new
observation point intuitively or at
least in if everything was one
dimensional you would expect that your
new mean would be a convex combination
of these two things
and it should be some kind of optimal
convex combination that's exactly what
we have here the new mean is a convex
combination of what we would guess just
from the model and what we think from
the data it's kind of a complicated
convex combination because the two
things live in different spaces do you
need matrices to make sure that you end
up in the right spaces the formula for
the covariance is not so important just
know that there is a formula for the
covariance so this this matrix K n plus
1 is called the kalman gain and this is
really the correct choice of convex
combination for your model and your data
it's determined by the covariances in
your observation and in your forecast so
I'll go back to the picture to explain
what I mean by that if you look at this
slide and imagine where should my new
main be I think it's a convex
combination of these two things the
amount that I moved by will depend a lot
on how much I trust each of those two
things if my observation was perfect if
the noise was zero or extremely small I
would really move exactly two acts if my
forecast was extremely spread out I
wouldn't really trust my forecast that
much if I had a huge covariance in the
forecast I wouldn't trust it that much
so I would trust if I'm thinking about
what kind of convex combination i want
to take between the observation in the
forecast in that scenario it would be
for the observation but you might have
situations where the forecast is
extremely tight so where this blue
circle here would be really small and
you would trust your model a lot and
your observation maybe you don't trust
at all in that case you want to take a
contact a convex combination which is
more in favor of the model in the
observation so there's an optimal choice
I'll cut a correct choice of convex
combination which is really just a
function of these two covariances the
covariance in your observational noise
and the covariance of this blue circle
which I'll call the forecast covariance
how much do you trust your forecast
so it's going to be an important idea
when we start looking at more
complicated things and common filters ok
so that's common filters so what do we
do when we're not linear so in
particular if we just don't assume that
size linear anymore it's not a matrix as
a function so the simplest thing that
you can do in meteorology it's called
the three evar algorithm they started
using it in the 60s and the u.s. still
uses it nobody else uses it but the US
still uses it it's a really simple idea
you're basically trying to get a state
estimate MN using something like a
common update formula so we like this
intuition we like the intuition that our
new estimate should be a convex
combination of the two pieces of
information we have the forecast and the
observation that intuition still makes
sense when the model is nonlinear you
can still take your old estimate of the
state apply your non linear map to it
and get a new guess of what it was just
based on the model the problem is that
we no longer have an optimal choice of
the convex combination that was
something that we had because everything
was Goshen we knew what the covariances
were we could optimally pick which one
should be or how much we should trust
the forecast in the observation because
we knew how much we trusted our forecast
in nonlinear situation you don't really
have that you don't have formulas for
covariances so what 3 D var says is it
just says hope that there exists such a
K and find it by tuning well maybe you
don't even need to tune that much maybe
it'll work without any tuning so hope
that you can pick some convex
combination of your mean and your
observation in such a way that you track
the truth well and this is really kind
of an you're breaking away from the
Beijing situation because you're only
producing the mean here you're not
producing anything about
distribution you're just producing one
vector which is tracking the state
that's all so the animation that I
showed you earlier this is actually
three D var so each one of these things
is a different em there's a different
thing tracking the state and you can see
well so I didn't do this whatsoever I
just picked so the H is my observation
function it looks like that because I'm
only observing the X variable and then I
just picked well let's see if 111 works
it works pretty well so a lot of the
time you don't actually have to do any
tuning to get these things to work so we
had these ten different things which
started off not very good but by just
assimilating the ax data in a really
crude way we're able to make them
synchronize so also notice something
which is that all the particles or sorry
all the different state estimates before
converging to the correct signal they
converge to each other this is kind of a
bad thing because if you imagine that
you were running a hundred predictions
and all of them did the same thing you
would be assuming something about your
uncertainty you would be thinking well
maybe if all of my predictions are the
same they have to be close to the truth
if there was any uncertainty they should
be doing different things the fact that
they all jump on top of each other tells
me something about how certain I should
be about my prediction but actually they
jump on top of each other and they're
not on the true signal so that's a
problem with 3d far so you might be able
to synchronize eventually but you don't
necessarily know too much about
uncertainty quantification
[Music]
so the three devo algorithm you can
actually mathematically prove that it's
accurate so some of my research is to
prove things about algorithms like this
you can mathematically prove that for
quite large classes of models it's
accurate in the sense that if you let it
run for long enough for even not great
choices of K you will synchronize with
the true state but it assumes it's a few
things it assumes that you're observing
enough of the variables so your
observation operator isn't not too
sparse can be quite sparse but it's not
too sparse you also need to assume that
the observational noise is not that huge
so the theorems that you end up proving
are typically in the long time limit you
converge to some kind of band around the
true trajectory and the width of that
band is proportional to your
observational noise so if you're all so
obstinate was huge then that band would
be useless
so 3d virus accurate when obtuse parse
you can't necessarily expect accuracy
you might expect that there's lots of
different possible answers and 3d VAR
just picks one of them maybe all of your
copies of three diva picked the wrong
one so how can you want to be able to
say that in situations where you can't
necessarily figure out everything about
the true trajectory maybe you want to
say something about the posterior
instead just those three D var help me
with that it turns out it doesn't it
doesn't have any uncertainty
quantification at all doesn't tell you
anything about the covariance of your
posterior doesn't tell you anything
about the distribution whatsoever it
just gives you one state estimate so we
would like an algorithm which in
addition to a state estimate told us
something about uncertainty so we want
something that tells us about the
posterior and not just gives us a state
estimate so this is what something
called an ensemble kalman filter does so
an ensemble kalman filter it uses an
ensemble of particles that are
interacting with each other and they're
trying to represent they're trying to
look like samples from this distribution
so in particular if you looked at the
main of your ensemble that should be
close to the mean of this distribution
if you looked at the covariance of that
ensemble it should tell you something
about the covariance of this
distribution so the en k f as it's
called this is what Canada uses and it's
battle and Europe uses it in combination
with a few other things and Europe a
kind of state-of-the-art at weather
prediction okay so how does the nkf work
so you want to maintain this ensemble
it's an ensemble just like in that
picture we had an ensemble of state
estimates now we have an ensemble where
all the particles are coupled together
[Music]
so we want them to represent the whole
posterior and not just the mean each
particle is updated just like three DVR
so you find some sort of convex
combination for each single one of your
particles you find a convex combination
of what you predict it should be so you
take your previous particle you apply
your nonlinear dynamics to it to see
where where you predict that it particle
would go just based on your model you
combine it with data and you want to
find some sort of optimal combination of
these two things remember that to pick
the right convex combination you want to
have you want to have some knowledge of
how certain you are about the two pieces
of information you want to know
something about the covariance of your
forecast distribution and the covariance
of your observational noise we know the
covariance of our observational noise
that's nothing to do with non-linearity
we don't know anything about the
covariance of the forecast but if we
have an ensemble than we do if we have
an ensemble of particles we can use that
ensemble to say something about the
covariance you take your ensemble we
flow it forward under your model this
tells you something about how much you
trust your model tells you something
about the covariance of your model so
you take that empirical covariance from
the ensemble and you feed it into the
common formulas as if it was the real
covariance and that's what you do that's
an ensemble common filter okay so i'll
give you the same picture but with an
ensemble rather than actual
distributions so you can understand the
idea so you start with an ensemble which
represents your posterior at time n so
think of this as like samples from the
real distribution you apply your
dynamics to all of them so each one of
those points you just apply the dynamics
and it goes to one of those points this
tells you it gives you some kind of
approximation of the forecast
distribution gives you an empirical
approximation of the forecast
description in particular you can use
the empirical mean of this to figure out
what is the mean of the forecast
distribution or approximated you can use
the empirical covariance to figure out
how much you trust that distribution
you then make an observation and you
shift each one of those particles using
the common formula and this gives you a
new empirical representation of a
posterior so Canada uses this they use
it for operational numerical weather
prediction nwp numerical weather
prediction there's an amazing thing
about en KF so I've sold this to you as
it's kind of a sampling algorithm it's
like we're trying to represent a
probability distribution using samples
for numerical weather prediction you're
trying to represent a random variable
which is enormously high dimensional
it's a billion dimensional you need a
lot of samples to represent something
that is a billion dimensional the amount
of samples that you need typically
scales exponentially with the dimension
of the state so you would need
exponential of a brilliant variables to
come up with a good representation of
this measure Canada uses it with a
hundred and it works so it's an amazing
and mysterious thing about the ensemble
kalman filter that allows you to use it
for extremely high dimensional models
with a very low number of particles the
intuition you should have is that a lot
of these models are not as high
dimensional as they seem an example of
that so the navier-stokes equations it's
an infinite-dimensional PDE you can
actually prove that just like the
Lorentz equation it has a finite
dimensional attractor there's some
finite amounts finite dimensional
subspace of an infinite dimensional
space that your dynamics always get
sucked into most of the dynamics are
just dissipation they're just
high-energy things that go away in time
the interesting things that are hard to
predict happen on a finite dimensional
space en k f is good at finding this
finite dimensional space that's how you
should think about this
so this is another line of direction for
mathematicians trying to figure out how
you can use the fact that these models
have effective lower dimensionality to
prove that en careful really work and
the intuition is that this this
covariance the forecast ensemble it
doesn't explore the boring directions of
your enormous space it only explores the
directions where your model varies the
most because that's what covariance does
so just like in that picture where we
had the blue ellipse the covariance
stretched out in the directions where
you had the most forecast variance in
extremely high dimensional state you
might only have forecast variance in
some of the variables in the load and a
much lower dimensional set of variables
so I'll show you an animation that'll
convince you that en calf is not perfect
[Music]
this is another toy model it's called
the well I call it this sombrero ste so
probably a lot of you don't know what
stds are but that's alright I'll explain
it to you you should think of this model
as a point living in that sombrero what
the point wants to do is move to the rim
of the sombrero wants to minimize its
height on the sombrero so it wants to
fold just like a marble if you dropped a
marble in the sombrero and it will fall
down to the rim the marble has its own
inherent vibration it's got noise which
means that even though it falls down
once it gets there rattles around a lot
and it'll rattle around the sombrero so
if you looked at this thing from above
it just looks like the kind of noisy
thing walking around a circle so it's a
two-dimensional state well I think of it
as two-dimensional state because it's
just a noisy thing walk around a circle
so what happens if we only observe the X
variable so we want to try and track
this thing which is moving around the
sombrero and we are in the observing
next variable
so this is a MK f with lots and lots of
particles for a two-dimensional system
the red star is the true thing which is
producing the observations producing the
data and what we'll see is that over
time your ensemble clusters on the truth
just good so there's a few that get left
over on the top but eventually they all
get sucked down the reason for this is
that non-gaussian states for this
ensemble are very unstable so if you had
if you had if you had an example where
your particles were spread out and they
looked like there were samples from not
a Gaussian thing that would be very
unstable and it would pick some kind of
cash so even though they started off
spread out they got sucked down to the
right thing so you imagine what the
system is seeing its observing the X
variable just there it doesn't actually
know which branch it's on it doesn't
know if it's on the top of the bottom so
he gets sucked down because non-gaussian
things are unstable for an ensemble
kalman filter I'll show you the exact
same thing with the exact same
trajectory of the truth all we're doing
is using a different noise in the model
for making predictions which is
something that would happen in real life
so you'll see that the red star does
exactly what it before I mean I guess
you might remember what I did before but
trust me all we're doing is using
different noise in the model for the
ensemble to make for the forecast
prediction it gets sucked to the wrong
thing so you can think of this as a
problem with uncertainty quantification
both of those two situations you would
make a prediction and you would get some
certainty about it and in versus them
you'd be wrong so in the right in the
first one you'd actually be making the
right prediction but you wouldn't be
capturing the posterior correctly the
posterior should be concentrated on the
two branches because you don't know
which one you're on
the nkf will kind of pick the Gaussian
of best fit so en ke f is not good at
finding very non-gaussian posterior so
the last thing I'll show you is
something which is much better I won't
tell you anything about this but enough
time this is a particle filter so en ke
f is it has the ambition of being a
sampling algorithm but it's not a
sampling algorithm it's not actually
sampling from the real posterior its
sampling from some kind of Gaussian
approximation of it which makes it a lot
cheaper and it makes it work really well
in high dimensions particle filter is
something which actually does sample
from the posterior so you can see that
it does the right thing the particles
now hover on the two branches
[Music]
sorry
the four things that I've introduced for
the last one I haven't really introduced
essentially what researchers are trying
to do now is they're trying to expand
figure out in what directions these
things don't work in what they do and
see if they can break the barriers
between so common field has your obvious
barrier of only working for linear
models 3 D var works for nonlinear
models but has terrible uncertainty
quantification quantification no
uncertainty quantification en KF it's
extremely efficient works in high
dimensions gives you some uq uncertainty
quantification but not for non-gaap
shins particle filters this thing that I
just showed you on the last side and
didn't tell you anything about these
really give you intelligent information
about a posterior they're horribly
inefficient in large dimensions so this
intuition I gave you that the number of
samples that you need scales
exponentially with the dimension that's
really true for particle filters so what
people are doing these days in research
is to try and sort of blur the lines
between these algorithms see if you can
take some intuition for me and KF and
apply it to particle filters to make
particle filters give you intelligent
information but work better in hide
emotions ok thank you for listening I
put all my slides on my website if you
want to see those pretty animations
again thanks
[Applause]
so David will be available for office
hours in the room below this one so you
can find them there and we'll have five
minutes while we set up the next speaker